[Music]
it was love at first sight when I saw
her I knew there she was with her
chocolate brown eyes and looking cute
and making cute little squawking noises
and I got her we were walking putt by
the Kitty cages and all of a sudden
Melvin kind of reached his little paw
out and grabs me having these photos
would just be a memory that I'll always
have of how happy I am when I'm with her
and I've had her for 12 years longest
relationship yeah so this is an
opportunity for me to tell people rescue
a parrot if you want a parrot Melvin is
a kitten he's only four months old so I
think having him in this age and me and
my age is like gonna capture the time
when we kind of got to know each other
in my spare time pro bono attorney for a
couple parrot conservation organizations
says I've gotten to know more about
African Gray parrots I realized if one
must have one they should rescue but
they're taken out of the Congo by the
hundreds in crates most of them dive so
many people give them up and once you
have a parrot in your home it is for the
most part too late for that parrot to
ever be in the wild again yeah I've kind
of made it my mission to get people to
reconsider if they don't have 900 square
miles for a cage then they probably
shouldn't get a parrot and if they must
definitely adopt there are tons of them
out there they need homes and they're
super super loving I had a 21 year old
cat named blossom who passed away in
August and I never thought I would ever
get another cat again
he is very hyper and energetic which is
great but it's kind of like a baby where
like you have to watch him or he gets
into stuff all in all it's an amazing
experience I have a little built-in best
friend I heard this dog screaming
outside and the gardener's had come that
day I guess the gate got left open and
it was like oh no that's that's her and
I ran outside she had been hit by a car
and this car had just kept going when I
ran up to her her tail started wagging
because she was just happy to see me her
pelvis was totally shattered and they
told us that we could either operate or
put her down in 2015 I was diagnosed
with a hip condition like I woke up one
day and I just couldn't walk anymore
when I finally went in for surgery I
just kept they
kang allah also had pelvic
reconstruction and if she can do it and
she's this small and i could do it too
tell me Bob this dog is the love of my
life like I cannot imagine what my life
would be like without her so today is
the unwrapping never had pictures of
chiku before done professionally just
what my apartment needs your model we
can put this in your portfolio now chiku
it's great she's so beautiful oh so cute
this embodies us perfectly I think that
these photos showing us together all
healed up and so happy we're just two
goofy gals haha best pals
very handsome I love it this is going on
the wall what do you think
hey chiku okay she likes it I feel like
we look the same in this picture like
our eyes are very similar and he's 100%
my son I never saw the resemblance
before but now it's pretty clear like
this is my guy yes you should 100% get a
pet photoshoot done I mean you can take
pictures on your phone or take Instagram
stories that having these printed out in
high quality there's someone I have in
my house forever my kids are probably
gonna look at this one day I'll probably
leave this to her so she can remember me
when I'm dead